It's me, Marcio, and it's me, Marci, and it's me, Marcio,
and it's me, Marcio, and it's me, Marcio, and it's me, Marcio, and it's me, Marcio,
and it's me, Marcio, Marcio, from, from, from, super Marcio RPG, and totally not the
The Allure Gen 1 Indulge.
Ha ha ha ha!
Yeah!
Look at that, got my attack up too.
Yes, hit yourself.
Why are you hitting yourself?
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
But welcome everyone, thank you for bringing everyone here, I really appreciate it!
Keep yourself safe.
In game, of course.
Am I allowed to go this way?
I don't know.
I'm going back.
Hold on.
I need to go shopping.
Who are you?
This bus is undergoing repairs.
Sorry, I need to go shopping, I forgot.
I need to get new items.
No weapons, weapons!
Yeah, yeah, I need new weapons.
Yeah.
Woohoo!
How wild did they just let us in and out now?
Yeah!
Give me a second.
Do you have stuff here?
I hope to serve the king again soon.
Smellas, I remembered him.
He used to be so small, so timid.
Now look at him!
You know about the royal bus?
No!
It's a real vehicle, only used by the king.
It's parked now due to the fact he's ill.
King Nimbus loves statues and birds.
He has scads of them in the castle.
Let me jump on things.
Ah!
No!
Jump!
Wait, can I jump on the pillows?
Whee!
Boing!
At the cartridge of this game?
I don't know if I have the cartridge of this game.
But...
This is my first time playing it, so I'm playing the remake.
He used to be able to walk through the castle freely,
but I guess we shouldn't disturb the king now.
You know, volcano?
Not yet.
Panos to the east.
I wish I could take a dip in the springs.
There's a spring there!
Do they have...
Oh, there it is!
Wait, there's like a whole section back here.
Is there like a secret person here?
Secret thing?
No?
Dang it.
Welcome!
So you want to take a rest?
I'm sure that's why you're here.
Be 30 coins a night.
Oh, thanks.
Please come back again.
Let me use this.
Whee!
Do they have a...
Oh, wait!
It's down here.
Oh, stairs!
Oh, these are beds!
I thought they were tables!
I'm kind of stupid!
I want, I want...
I want to go to hot springs.
It seems so relaxing and stuff.
Ten pie!
Oh!
Sorry.
I missed, I missed, I missed a tip.
Wait a minute.
Thank you for the $1 tip.
Anonymous.
Hi, Mercy.
I'm in here, but I love your design already.
This Mercy, I mean...
You remind me of my favorite yander
and Chunni Gyo character in my favorite anime.
Why are the crazy girls always the most loyal?
Because we love you!
I mean, Mercy certainly loves you!
A lot!
Super a lot!
Aha!
And...
Thank you for the $1.45.
Super Benny Garnes.
Hello, Mercy.
My beloved, how are you doing today?
If Mercy was here...
If Mercy was here and totally not Mercy,
Mercy would totally say,
say,
I'm doing great.
Hypothetically speaking,
if Mercy was here...
...
Wait!
That tomato?
Ha ha ha ha!
Jalfel is sleeping.
Jalfel's awake now!
Oh, damn.
Okay.
You die first, then.
Resistant!
Oh, yeah!
Ow!
Oh, he does a double punch!
You know what?
I'm gonna switch you out.
Sorry.
I need Gino here right now.
Oh!
There we go!
Whee!
Can I do a big Gino flash?
Ha ha ha!
What the...
What is that?!
Oh!
Ha ha ha ha!
Pinwheel!
That was such a slow thing.
Boop boop boop boop!
No coins!
God, they're so poor.
Shit!
Oh, man.
I need to get the timing better.
I am so bad at this right now.
Bop!
Ah!
Stop missing!
Thanks!
Ah ha ha!
Well, I don't know why.
Okay, Gino meme!
He ran away!
What a coward!
Timing hard!
I didn't pay attention to that.
I need to get the timing right.
Step five.
I accidentally hit mute didn't I I accidentally hit mute didn't I
oopsies oopsies okay where did I last stop okay cool the Mekka Koopa Stomp
we stomping on Koopa's by the way we should build a bit of magic into Bowser
Kohai and I was also reading reading I was thank you anonymous now I have to
read it again damn it thank you anonymous for the $1 tip high mercy I've
been watching clips senpai's have made and mercy's yandere raid always makes me
laugh especially those moments where she gave bad advice to her fans am I
messed up for thinking a jealous mercy is kind of hot I feel like a lot of you
guys is our mass of kiss I'm master kisses this is this is this here we'll
put in some stuff in the magic yeah oh it's like a fan oh that's where that
leads oh I don't know about you but this this off fuck you anyways uh this
this saw this saw this saw BGM is so good this BGM is so good the heck
ah yes yes
Question for you, Mercio, other than you as Mario, who is the other Vialour members as Mario characters?
Oh shit, we had this discussion before.
Uhhh...
How'd they know? It was me!
Shibi is Luigi?
Lu Shibi?
Hahahaha!
And...
We thought...
Peach would be Icy...
Because...
Icy is a preen- is a PRINCESS!
Strony would be Yoshi...
Stro-shi?
Amy is told!
Yeah, Amy is told!
And...
Uhhh...
Azura...
Maybe we decided Azura was...
Bowser?
Hahahaha!
Because of the horns?
Bowser, right!
Hahahaha! We did do...
Azura as Bowser, because I thought of the horns.
Hahahaha!
Mu mu mu mu!
And that's how...
And that's how you get everyone!
But I definitely see Amy as, like, told.
Ah!
How'd they know that I was...
I was here and not a statue?
Ah!
What happened to my timing?
Oh, you're still asleep?
Yeah, we're good.
Hahahaha!
Wait, Amy being told is Timmy?
What about Serenity?
Ah, jeez.
I don't even know where to put Serenity, either.
Hahahaha!
Was...
Was Serenity?
If Amy I thought she would be Louie G since she's the younger sibling?
I prefer...
Well...
It's because...
I don't know.
Lush...
Lushibi...
Lou...
Sounded really good.
Hahahaha!
Ah!
Forgot her.
Triple move!
I just want to use the triple move now.
Guy, please, please.
I don't like that you all survived.
That bothers me.
Oh!
That's a big...
Hahahaha!
There we go.
Goodbye, Tomei Toll.
Okay.
Where's Yoshi? Got it.
There we go!
They actually do spin, though.
They actually do spin, so...
You can like...
Um...
You can follow the Yoshi and see where it lands.
Should I...
Should I start investing Mario in magic?
M-magic?
Ultra fireball!
Ooh!
Okay, you get more magic now.
Star rain!
You've always gotten magic.
There's nothing.
Otherwise, you're pretty useless.
The fuck did I hit?
Wait, where did they come from?
Where did they come from?
Now it shows the thing.
Yes, hit each other!
Hit each other!
Yes, good!
I can't believe it was real.
No, we haven't had any.
Oh, he's so chunky.
Wait, are they statues like our enemies?
He's so cute.
Oh, they're so cute!
I just want to hit him!
Man, actually, this is really hard.
Oh, I want to try this.
They're so cute!
They're so chonk!
I love them!
Yay!
Dino!
I think...
Dino's magic, right?
Those are for magics really good.
Hey, wait a minute, it's locked!
Why didn't you guard it if it's locked?
Yay, mushroom!
Knew it!
Okay, we're gonna get this.
We're gonna get this Senpai.
I actually have no faith in this.
Fuck you!
I really don't have...
Well, it's a good thing that gets stunned.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Fight each other!
Kill, kill, kill!
You know this way.
Big castle.
Stop hitting Mao!
Hold on, where's...
Need the mushroom.
Eat!
Eat, eat, eat!
Oh, thank goodness it's hitting itself.
Yeah!
Assh!
Yay!
Ooh, frowny coin!
We're here.
Senpai!
I need, I need to take...
I need to take...
A Nido meeting!
I need to get an idle meeting.
BRB!
I'm at the beginning now.
I'm going to go here now.
I need to get an idle meeting.
Ah.
Oh, it does kind of look like a Metroid.
Oh, thank you for the HP.
Shit.
Can I do like a Super Jump?
Fuck. I only did two.
That was my badge.
Magic.
That's a lot of people.
I blocked it!
Woo!
I'm so good at video games. Wow.
I'm such a gamer.
I'm so good at video games.
Oh, I beat my record by only one.
Shit.
Ow.
I'm going to see if I can do the jump.
Oh, only ten. I need more than double that.
I don't know why my timing is so off.
I'm so good at video games.
Man.
Well, we certainly aren't going to listen to your pointless chatter.
Frankly speaking, I'm not going to worry.
Without this key, the key can't go anywhere.
I said shut up already.
What the? That is an establishment. That's Mario.
How utterly rude. And who in blazes are you anyway?
Me? I'm the real prince. That's who.
And how dare you listen in on a private conversation.
If you're going to be this rude, I'm simply going to leave.
So long chumps.
Hey, Valentina ran away.
I think we kind of missed the ball here.
But I better get moving too. Come on, let's get them.
Okay, give us a minute.
Yeah, it's a recovery.
I can't shave.
Yeah.
Oh.
Shit it!
Just one super camp.
Just 15, still my record is just 15.
Yay, level up!
Oops.
Nice.
Senpai!
Senpai, give me a sec.
Oh no!
Senpai, thank you!
Gryffin07 for remembering for one month.
Ten days late, but congrats on one month.
Looking forward to many more with
our favorite Kohai.
Thank you!
Okay.
Does anyone else
try to block the camp block attacks me
all the time?
Back to saving.
Yeah.
How do you my health be okay?
Okay.
Since there's a special enemy,
we gotta kill it specially!
I suck at that one.
Oh, I feel so bad that I don't,
I don't, you know.
I haven't gotten past 15 yet.
Okay.
How am I gonna get 30?
So hard!
Am I just gonna do Dino Blast?
Sorry.
No, I shouldn't be wasting F key,
but there's just so many of them.
Yes, hit yourself.
Why are you hitting yourself?
You know it's getting a little low.
How about he gets...
Oh, hi!
Oh, shit.
Man, I could've hit him,
but I was too slow.
Okay.
Hold on.
Drupalg.
Yeah.
I'm low on FP now.
Wait, where's that?
Where's that?
More clouds!
Hustbings are ahead,
but I only royal take and bathe here.
You don't look so royal.
Right now Prince Malo is bathing in the hustbings.
Must be so relaxing.
Don't tell me I have to go back up.
Queen Valentina.
Queen Valentina,
is the king shown any improvement?
And how has his wife failed queen?
And Prince Malo, is he well?
No one, I think, I think...
Not only that, but...
In furthermore...
But then...
Pipe down, all of you!
I have better things to do
than to listen to your half-wit opinions.
And look, while I've been wasting my time
listening to your endless chatter,
Mario has managed to find me.
Doodle doodle!
Oh, that bird has a permanent brain cramp.
Doodle, do you hear me?
Get over here now, I need some help
entertaining Mario.
Doodle, do you hear me?
Get over here now, I need some help
entertaining Mario.
Don't move it!
Come here now!
Holy shit, she's...
Doodle, doodle, come here in a minute!
Holy shit, she's a...
You know...
Snatched?
Super snatched.
Wait!
Gino!
Fine, so be it.
Die by the power of the sun!
Ugh.
Finally.
I'm done.
Girls, where are my rooms?
Ow.
Wait, it made a loud sound, but it didn't do that much.
We're okay.
Sorry, I need FB.
Ow.
I got bitch slapped.
Man.
I like this one.
Ooh.
Oh, she's resistant to it!
Ow.
Maybe you'll get over this?
Oh shit, I fell asleep.
Gotta heal up.
Mario.
Dang it!
Why are you always falling asleep?
EEEEEE
Not at all. How could you lose already? Oh, come on, get over here.
I hit Valentina first. Well, it looks like I couldn't pick anyone else.
I don't have a lot of stuff.
Oh well, here we go. Oh, I got a freebie. Never mind, we're good.
Dang it.
Wow, it sucks.
Oh, I can actually hit Dota.
Oh, I can actually hit Dota. Okay.
Dang it.
Come on, group hug.
There we go.
Come on, only 10.
Come on, group hug.
That was a lot of damage, yeah.
Okay, let's go after her. I know she has the key.
Oh, he's got a parasol. Oh, is that Peach's parasol?
Woohoo! Wahoo! I mean, wahoo!
Mom, Dad, I'd like you to meet Mario and my other travel companions.
I say, how can we ever thank you enough? I'm Malo's father, King Nimbus.
Hello, everyone. Thank you so much for looking after my dear child.
Please allow me to introduce everyone. This is Princess Peach from the Mushroom Kingdom.
Ah, I've heard so much about you. May I have your autograph?
Don't embarrass us, junior dear. Oh, never mind. And who's this gentleman here?
This is Mario. He helped me from the start.
You don't mean the Mario jumping Mario autograph, please? That's quite enough, dear.
Okay, okay. And how about showing me just a little jump? Tiny hop will do.
Yay! Oh, even Bowser's hearing. Oh, fantastic!
This is Bowser, leader of Bowser's minion.
Oh, another famous person! This is just too much. I must have your autograph.
Oh, not even a little scribble? Okay, okay.
And this is Gino, who came from the starry sky, like I told you before.
Oh, yes! That story about the star... her star way! How awful!
That's... that star road.
Oh, right. Speaking of stars, a little while ago, a large star fell into the volcano.
I passed one of the star pieces. Hmm.
But the dreaded s-sarr-sarr-dre-sarr?
Dragon inhabits the volcano. It's gonna be tough getting a star out of there.
Perhaps all of you working together could handle the beast. Why, when I was young, I...
Yes, dear. Now, once at the volcano, find Cinder Toad. He'll be able to help you.
Before you go to the volcano, you ought to take a dip in our hot spring out back.
They're the pride of Nimbus Land. You be careful, everyone.
Okay, but we'll probably won't come back until we find the star.
I want... I want the hot spring.
Son, you're just like me when I was your age. I'm proud of you.
Well, I bet you'd enjoy the hot spring just as I did as a boy. Reach them through the back door here.
If you have any problems, come straight back, okay? We'll do whatever we can to help.
Star, right?
I want it again.
Wait, give me this...
Wait, am I supposed to fall again?
Aw, man.
Where are those treasures? Did I get them already?
The head are the hot springs, but only royalty is allowed.
Yep, you're the real prince! Sorry about the misunderstanding before.
There's no way that giant bird could have been a prince, huh?
No big deal, anyway. Do you think you can let us through here?
Of course!
Go right ahead. Please enjoy yourselves. Be careful not to fall into the volcano.
Wait, hold up.
Before I can...
There's something else I can get in town.
Wah!
What is it?
Did you get the seed and fertilizer? I have a seed!
Walk to the edge of town. This way?
Oh yeah, I saw Valentina go towards the building to the south. Wonder why.
Oh, oh, busted! What do I do? What do I do?
I'll give you this fertilizer if you let me go, okay?
Got fertilizer.
Can I go further?
How did that happen?
Building south, right?
Guys!
Guys, it's the thief!
What do I do? He's gonna steal my money!
Fuck you!
Hey, hey, we meet again. This here land is rich. It's got lots of loot, and I want it all.
Hey, I'm not sweating this device will tell me where the treasure is hidden.
Rest of them are mine! All mine! Adios, fools!
Oh, thanks. Found an echo signal. If you could fit.
I'll tell you the location of the hidden treasure.
You know Ring will let you know when there's a treasure near. Has no effect when not equipped.
Ow, give me a second.
So how does it work?
Do I... Does it just tell me?
Not yet.
So I should just wear it when I'm like in overworld stuff?
Okay, it's automatic. Okay, just gotta make sure to change it after.
What's this?
Oh, it's back to the overworld.
I want, I want to go to the hot spring, though.
He's got so much stuff.
Oh? In this window?
In this window?
Like around here?
Ah! Wow! It worked!
Oh, look! Oh, look! Everyone has a statue!
This statue seems all unworldly.
And to see the King's statue collection, I tell you, it's remarkable.
It's making a beeping sound as if it's the King's statue collection.
Ah!
It's making a beeping sound as if it's down here.
Oh, no!
Is it on top of the other box?
Dang it.
Oh, look!
How tricky of them!
Let's see the room here. Let me get to see the room here.
Hi! I'm able to serve the King again, but we left our houses wide open.
Hope everything's alright.
You gave me another job as a guard.
Good smell! Come by!
Thank you for the soup!
$2 Super Roast Town has an unlocked path.
A seed for fertilizer. Okay, I'll get up there soon.
So much! You were able to rescue my father.
The key you gave us. Don't mention it.
You rescued him.
Thank you zero zero seven bond six two for for joining a snippet.
Snippet memba tier. Thank you.
You too.
Prince.
Here it is from here. This is for me. Please take it.
Got our jar. Thank you.
You know that there are hot springs around here?
Yep.
Oh, you're no fun. I want to be the first to tell you.
You did tell me before.
Our jar. Yeah. Yeah.
You're looking especially fluffy today, Prince.
Yeah.
Wee.
Pleasure.
Oh.
Scenic route was worth it. I think so.
She's surrounded.
Danger beyond the edge is the volcano.
Oh.
This is nice.
Should I go there first or?
Should I go to Rosetown first and get the thing or go to the volcano right away?
Rosetown first. Okay.
Hmm.
Was this one? Yeah.
Wee.
Wrong way. This way.
Rosetown. Here it is.
New path. Oh, is this it?
Okay.
Got any cool stuff here?
Can I jump into the skies?
House.
Aye. I'm the gardener.
See that huge planner? I spent many years seeking the legendary seed and fertilizer.
Well, Phil, but it had no luck.
Well, I could find them.
Oh, incredible. I do believe that's the legendary fast-growing seed.
It was the enormous plant that seized my energy to change my life.
It was the youth when I was looking at the one day of my climb on my own.
I traveled all the world, scoured the library for it, and then in the end,
they said none of it was the youth's seed from the filling of the gardener.
It was the utmost important to me. I insisted.
Despite it headed over, really.
I can't read that fast, sorry.
Hey, I haven't finished yet.
That's my story. Will you give me the seed?
Sure. I finally have it.
It's extraordinary. I can't believe it.
This is a quick-acting fertilizer to Steve River.
I thought I would search it high and low in the world,
but it never came to find it, though.
I explored the cave to make contact with the beds of a clown in the bean valley
and hopefully to further utilize this national chance.
Exaggerating when I say,
I've realized their long-lived agreement of gardener paramount to the day.
Really, something. I can't do it.
Shall I attention span?
I'd say.
Yeah, you can have the fertilizer, too.
Thank you. I finally have both the seed and the fertilizer.
I'll try them out right away.
Plant the seed.
Give it fertilizer.
Nothing's happening.
Oh!
Oh, wow.
This is amazing.
Finally, my long-lived agreement of gardener paramount
if I would describe my feeling right now,
it would be a million against one. No, that's not quite right.
It's nothing. The bait and dame is giving me the mere words
but not suffice to extent that I've lost track of what I'm saying.
It's seemingly close to certain of the truth that no one would be able to suppress
the overwhelming feeling coming into possession of the planter.
It was not easy to believe,
but the plan was big enough, magnificent planter of my own dives.
Cannot get through as good enough
until I will be positive green with envy.
Anyways, yeah.
I think I could use a little more fertilizer.
Maybe not, huh?
This won't get me in half
the gardener monthly magazine.
I literally just went,
because there are some parts I couldn't read.
Oh, stop.
That's a lazy shell.
There's two of them?
Oh, who wears the armor then?
Well, here you go.
Wear the lazy dress.
Ooh, how nice.
We did it.
Oh, looks like I can just go like that.
Is there anything else?
Ooh, I didn't...
Aw, skid.
Do we need anything else now?
Probably not, huh?
We can go back to Booster Tower for a scene.
Booster Tower.
We found the Link in Samus, Camille?
No?
Hee hee.
Ooh, hitting treasure.
Ow.
Ooh!
Yay!
Booster Tower again?
Nothing.
Shit.
There we go.
I don't remember this guy.
I don't remember this guy. Who is this?
Who is this?
Hee hee.
Really sorry about before.
Here, I'll make it up to you. Hee ha.
We haven't find yet. Hee hee hee.
That was just practice. Time for real.
Up to it. Hee hee.
Do I fight him again?
Is he gonna be ridiculously hard?
I didn't save.
Okay, sure.
Guess which hand.
The yellow ball is in.
If you can.
If you can, now watch carefully.
Which hand, ball, is it?
Touch the hand you think is holding in this one.
Very good, he's a prize for the winner.
I don't know, well it's true.
Oh cool, anything else?
Is it this one?
Yeah.
Oh cool, I'm getting good use to this.
Okay.
Back to this one, right?
Yeah.
Hee hee hee.
How many times can I do this?
Oh no, I missed it.
This one? Hee hee wrong.
This hand, you lose. Let's do it again sometimes.
Oh well.
Oops, I missed that one.
Hee hee.
No penalty, yeah.
Remember to respect your elders.
Can't I just go in again?
Yeah.
Wait, if I beat it like 12 times,
I get a membership?
Hold up.
Yay.
Oh.
Gambling.
But not really because I'm watching where the ball goes.
Rotten mush.
Oops, wrong hand.
How many times?
How many times has it been?
No penalty.
Oops.
How many times has it been?
No penalty.
Whoa! We did it!
What was that?
Oh, there was...
Alright, there's a light.
Go gambling!
Huh?
Huh! Yay!
Oh!
I'm still bad.
Don't need to figure out how this one.
Okay, gotta work on the timing.
Huge!
Okay.
Oh, okay, I got...
Ooh, 420!
Blaze it!
Ha ha ha!
I forgot how this one goes.
Okay.
Whee!
Totally forgot how to do this.
Okay.
Yes!
This way?
I can't remember which way it is.
Okay.
Oops.
No.
You know why, since I was here, yeah.
Okay.
Bitch slap!
Shit.
Okay.
Whee! Yesee!
I can't remember.
Oops.
Okay.
Am I getting it?
I just follow it.
I don't know.
It's not moving that fast in my opinion.
Ha ha ha!
I love this one.
Okay.
Ooh!
Senpai!
Thank you all for the 5 Super Innochi.
Also, I think you should be able to acquire the Iron Slash Metal Plate from Movil now.
It's Peach's best weapon.
Okay, thank you.
Okay.
Oops.
Is it on there again?
That was really close to here.
Not on top of the box again, is it?
Oops.
Is it?
Oh, this is gonna be hard. I'm not good at platforming.
Why?
What?
I don't know if I can jump on it.
Okay.
I did it!
Now where's the other one?
Ah!
Got it!
Okay.
What are you babbling about?
Wait, what?
Valentina's here?
Why should I marry you?
What a wonderful thing to say.
What are you whispering about?
What do I do?
Are they getting married?
You just leave them be, okay.
Oh, I just have to climb all the way back down now?
Ow, I forgot about you.
Oops.
I'm trying to go.
Oh!
Okay.
I almost thought I didn't get it that time.
Oh, I've already been here.
Ow.
Still gotta learn how to do it better.
Okay.
Gotta get out of here.
Oops.
Okay.
Mercy is a god tier Mario gamer.
I think that's the only thing I'm good at in Mario.
Or okay at in Mario.
Is the,
Is the, what's the word?
the sort of item.
Check out where the item is.
Okay, so it was Movil, right?
Movil's this way.
Wow, I'm so slow.
This shop?
This is the rest shop.
This one?
Good to see you.
I'll show you my inventory.
Item number one, a lucky jewel.
Sure to bring you plenty of good luck.
I'll set to you for 100 points.
Should I get it? No.
Number two, a mystery egg.
I have no idea what it does.
It sort of grows on you, huh?
Guys for 200.
Uh, no thanks.
Number three, a feather.
Just fell right off from the sky all of a sudden.
I picked up it off from the ground, but it's real jam.
No.
All I got for now.
Well, I didn't see metal anything.
Is it here?
No.
Nope.
No, he has it?
No.
Oh, did I not get it yet?
Did he not get it yet?
Senpai.
Thank you, you know,
GA again for the two.
Unless, might be after the barrel, but you know, I apologize.
It's okay.
We got our best.
And now we're doing it again.
What happened if I fall off here?
Oh, money.
I think this is the,
the evil one.
This one?
Oh yeah, this one.
The vines, the jump.
I don't want to do it again.
Senpai.
One more thing.
Do you have the shiny stone?
I'm not in the monster town yet.
Yeah, and he beat my ass so badly.
He beat my ass real badly,
and it really hurt.
Ah!
It's Hal.
Like it.
Ow!
Oh, stop!
Oops.
Bitch slap.
I'm still needing to work on my,
my timing for this.
I kind of suck at it.
Ah!
Yeah!
Hey, let me jump on you.
Dang it.
Why, why do you have so many?
Ah!
Yo-yo.
There you go.
That was tough.
Maybe I should by beat him.
Donkey Kong, why are you here?
It missed!
Oh!
Oh, man.
Oh, I missed.
I'm getting more clumsy with my stuff.
Goodbye, Donkey Kong.
Ooh, level up.
Step pie!
Okay, so Dark...
Thank you, you know, T for the 10.
So Dark Mario Lore here.
That is Nazi K. What?
In fact, that is one of the many Kongs that Mario imprisoned in the arcade days.
He just let loose in the wild instead of putting it out of his misery.
What?
What the?
What? Is this like a game theory?
Is this a game theory?
That's not hard.
Wait, no, why?
What do you mean it's not a game theory?
Not even joking?
Wait, what?
No, you're fucking with me.
You're fucking with me now.
Yeah, you're fucking with me.
I knew it.
You shouldn't...
You shouldn't tell me things like that.
I'll believe you.
I'll believe you because I'm gullible.
That is a very funny game theory, though.
I never tell you some pies that I hate ants.
I hate ants specifically because last year...
Was it last year or is it this year?
Oh man, I can't remember.
Things are just a blur now.
I'm pretty sure it was last year.
Yes, it was last year.
I went to Vietnam.
And...
I got attacked by fire ants.
Mind you, I'm gonna tell you some pie.
I have unlocked new trauma that I never thought I would unlock in my entire life.
And that's being...
Getting crawled all over
by a bunch of fire ants
and being bitten by ants.
That's a...
That is like being surrounded
and like crawled all over.
Yeah, that was awful.
I was bit everywhere.
It was...
It was painful and I hated it.
And now I have a big
disgusting hate for ants.
I hate ants.
Like, a lot now.
Thank you for the 333 tip, tiny spiny.
Yeah, that's not their real lore.
Nor is it even applied.
He's just wrong.
It's a fun little...
Just a fun little thing, some pies.
Just a fun little game theory.
Anyways, I hate ants.
They're good for the environment.
They're very strong, but...
My gosh.
So I hate them now.
I hate ants.
Like, yeah, I don't like ants.
For that very reason.
Shit.
Yay!
Love walk.
The heck did I hit anyways?
Okay, what? Okay, good question.
Why are there so many special enemies right now?
Step 5!
Thank you, Inochi for the 5!
But serious!
It is a strong believed and theorized
that it is in fact one of the
I hate Mario in prison and Nintendo swapped that under the rug.
Ahhhhhh!
OK, senpai, don't fight, OK?
Don't fight, don't fight, it's OK.
It's OK, it's fun.
I like to think of this.
It's super, super fun.
Ahhhhh!
Don't fight now!
Don't fight!
I like that, I like that thought.
We got big Nintendo here doing a cover up on Donkey Kong and Donkey Kong clone.
Ha ha ha ha clone.
I'm gonna switch out.
I think it's fine, it's fine, it's fun!
It's fun!
Another one!
Speak of the devil and they appear!
Mario!
Thank you for the Tui no chi!
Mario lore also says that brick blocks are toes.
Brick blocks?
Like...
Wait!
Hold up!
There's a gr-
What the fuck are you?
I'm useless without health.
I got it!
Aw man, this is gonna be rough.
Fuck!
Oh fuck.
Another one!
Maybe I should attack one of these guys.
I'm getting the timing so badly.
Who said I was a gamer?
It fooled me to the beginning!
We're fine!
Wait, there's another one up there!
Thank you for the Tui!
Breaking brick blocks, it grows brutally, ending a toad's life.
That's a lot of theories right now!
It's fun!
I wonder how you get it?
Don't tell me.
I have to fall.
There you go.
I'm not gonna make it out of here without FP.
This is really painful without FP.
Senpai!
Thank you!
Taigabia for the 53 tip.
Tui's Mario lore.
Mercial was moved as an alt character for being too cute.
Wait, 3 something and you're not even dead?
I forgot about this.
Do I?
Oh yeah.
Fuck.
Fuck, I'm stuck.
Not again.
This is so much.
Wait, does it always send me to the beginning?
Fuck!
No!
Please! Please!
It didn't even get any of me an exclamation mark.
Whatever. Fuck it.
How's that?
I need FP.
This is bad.
Oh, and my HP not great.
Okay, here we go.
Bitch.
I just don't think I...
Oh!
Okay, that's not bad.
I feel like I'm gonna get screwed soon.
Man.
We're here, nothing.
Oh, I'll revive him soon.
I'll revive him now.
I'm doomed.
Hold up.
I can't remember what was good, the ghost medal. Yes.
No.
I need switch.
Fuck!
He's gonna use Peach, but I don't have enough thingies.
Here we go.
Bracer? It's a bracer.
Should I put him into physical or magic? Maybe more magic?
Oh, hi. Hold on.
Hey there. Those footsteps.
Well, those footsteps were you for a minute. I thought I was hearing things.
Cinder told, this place is a regular inferno. Come on, step inside.
I'll come to the item shop.
Just you?
Ian, 30 coins will get you a room.
I can't stay all right.
I need the armor.
Probably, should I wear the armor?
I don't know if these are worth it because some of these are put down.
Oh no, this one doesn't look that good.
And I need FB, so yeah, I'll sleep.
Great. I'll get everything ready for you.
I'm just sleeping on the car, on the boxes!
Now wasn't that a cushy bed?
There are these.
Do I need any more items?
I probably need these.
Yeah.
Thanks for stopping that, but you can always come back, you know.
Aw, thanks.
Lives here all by himself? Kind of sad.
What do I do with all these flowers? Hold on.
Aw man.
Ah!
Shit.
Yay.
Ah!
Oi.
Thank you, Joker, for remembering for one month a snippy memory tier.
I swear the Marseille Alpha gets more scuffed every stream.
What do you mean, more scuffed every stream?
It looks perfect!
Ten-pecky!
Ah!
Never.
This is my, this is my weakest genre.
Ah!
But I'm warming hard.
Look at the shadows, shadows, shadows.
Look at the shadows and everything went away!
We did it! We made it to the boss!
He's really cute!
That's the dragon!
Yeah, him!
I got this.
I think I got this.
Oops.
Yeah. Fuck.
Wait, I won? That was it?
No, there's more, right? There's a second round, right?
I knew it! I knew it! I knew that was a second round!
Where is that pure water?
Why didn't that work?
What am I supposed to do now?
Good weakness!
weakness found!
Can't block it.
Does that mean I can do this one?
Okay, I'm gonna need Bowser to...
No!
Bowser, no!
Okay.
Bowser, I don't want Bowser to die!
Oh wait, he's okay.
Here!
We got it!
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, that's mine!
We got the star!
Amazing.
We're unbeatable!
Gorgeous!
You better leave now, chumps.
No, wait, wait! My star! My star! Give it back!
What the fuck? I worked so hard for that!
Hey Red, look down there! That's gotta be the ugliest mustache I've ever seen!
Yo, girls!
That guy's worse looking than that Claude Mario!
That IS Mario, you idiot!
Listen everyone, we gotta get the star to the blade immediately! We'll deal with Mario later!
My star! My star! My star! My star!
My star, come on!
Hey Red, careful with this, you're all thumbs!
Give it back! Wait, the game is back!
What the fuck?
None of them will be! I mean, none of them page!
Where's the blade?
Wait, what do you mean I have like three different boss fights? What the hell? That's just rude.
Back in the day, this is where I quit. I saved in a bad spot.
I hope I'm okay.
It'll be here. Are you sure?
Relax people!
Mario! Mario's here!
Too late.
Where's the blade?
Shut up already!
Finally!
Wait, give it back!
This is Power Rangers! We fight for evil!
We live for disorder!
We like what we do!
We struggle for chaos!
We are...
The Axe of Rangers!
Star peace gives people hope! It needs to be destroyed!
Alright.
You know what this means, pals.
We kill the pink one first. She heals.
We kill the pink one because she heals!
We kill the pink one! The pink one goals!
Fuck.
I'm gonna need Peach here.
We're good!
Aw, man.
Am I always missing?
You're dead!
What? My makeup's running!
And change brands!
You're dead!
Good plug.
Aw, man.
Like, can I not hit the girl?
I want him gone then.
Yo, Ren, what? Not a headache. Totally out of shape!
I always miss you, so...
Aw, man.
Yo, Ren, what? I'm hungry.
Chew on your tongue!
Yo, Ren.
Yo, Ren, what? I broke my shades.
Serves you right!
Okay.
Enough now, I'm angry! I'm gonna finish this!
Formation Hall! Here we go!
I'm gonna try this.
Dang it.
Force Beam Energize! Maximum Charge! Now!
Fire the Breaker!
Aw, man.
This isn't possible! We're invincible!
Can't be happening to the Axeum Rangers!
Woooah!
We only got 17 EXP for that?
Really?
We only got 17 for that?
Well, at least we got the star!
Yay, we got it!
That means we only need one more!
Okay.
Six Star Pieces have finally been collected.
Where did the last star piece be?
The last star piece was in your heart!
Oh, I'm going back to the other town.
Okay.
Nah.
Mystery Egg. I hate eggs.
No.
Metal Plate. Here it is. I'll take it.
Nice job doing business with you. Here you go. That's all I got for now. Okay.
That's... wait, a pip?
There we go.
Ah!
Now I need to save.
Now I can funk everyone with the...
Have you seen that one guy who's got a Swillings...
Do you know Swillings, the brand Swillings?
Okay.
Well, there's a brand called Swillings.
I think it's a German brand, I think.
Anyways, the knife brand. Yeah, like the knife, but like it's...
I think it was a Swillings frying pan.
So, this guy said he beat the shit out of this burglar.
And he showed the pan and it looked in pristine condition and I was like,
that's one way to sell a frying pan.
Swilling, right?
Yeah, with the frying pan.
And it looked pristine.
I was like, wow, not even a dent or anything. That's like sturdy, wow.
I think it was a regular frying pan.
And I was like legitimately impressed by how well it stood up.
And I was like, wow, I might...
If I needed to, I could use...
I would buy a frying pan like that.
Now who do we ask?
We talk to the parents?
I need to talk to the parents? Where do I go now?
Nobody's in the place.
Frog fuchsious guy.
I have frog.
Also, where's the casino?
Actually, I was right about the parents. I had to go to the parents.
What's the fastest way to the throne room?
Go through, right?
Immediately ask, where's the casino? Not addicted. I'm not addicted.
I just want to know.
I like how there's like all these statues of us.
You're as endless. I'm canny.
Just curious.
Just curious, you know.
Don't you ever just want to know where the casino is?
Um, dad.
Were you able to find the star, dear?
Yeah. The axon rangers took it away from us, but we got it back.
That's wonderful. Now the star, uh, the star way can be repaired, right?
I guess not. You're still missing a piece, I take it.
The last star?
Wait, the only place left to look is in Bowser's Keep.
Yeah, we know, but there's no way to get in. Believe me, we tried, but...
Yes, yes, even Mario can't jump that far.
All right, I'll let you use the...
That's it, dear. You should use the royal bus.
Yes, Malo, the time has come for you to take the bus.
Are they telling him to take the short bus?
Sorry, the way the nose goes down on my face is so funny.
I'm sorry.
My face is so funny.
Why when I was your age?
Really? Are you sure it's all right?
Of course, dear.
Wait, of course, dear.
I'll order the repairman to have it fixed up by the time you leave.
You simply have to help Mario and the others get that last star.
You bet, Mom.
Come on, Mario, let's go.
I'm going to get this star strip fixed for...
Good, best of luck.
Please, please promise me you'll make everyone's dream come true once again.
Yeah, yeah.
Say what?
Wrong way again.
You're acting like I didn't want to see this animation.
I like the way he holds his hat going...
Wahoo!
The bus has finally been repaired.
We can start operating again.
Prince Malo!
Why don't you go to Bowser's Keep?
Can you give us a lift, please?
I heard the story from King Nimbus.
You'll be there in no time.
Here it comes! Here it comes!
It looks like a taxi!
Look at Uber!
So how's the engine running?
Oh, it's purring like a kitten.
Do you take Prince Malo to the entrance of Bowser's Keep?
Of course! Can't wait to get this thing running again!
Come on, Prince! Hop on board!
All aboard!
We're off!
It just looks like a...
It doesn't look like a bus!
It looks like a...
Like a taxi...
Or a shuttle.
Ah!
The center-boiling lava.
It's so nice to be home.
Smithy's gonna pay for stealing my flooded castle for me!
Can I... Can I go back, though?
Can I start gambling?
Can I go back?
Step-pie!
Oops. That's how she's metal.
Oh, thank you, you know, she probably can get the metal plate in Mobile now.
Oh, I already did!
There's Bean Valley.
Hold on, I got so confused.
Eh, what a...
Wait, I did? I passed it?
Oh, right here!
Wow, I'm dumb.
Where is it?
And I exited.
Wait, where is it?
Ow.
This way?
No.
Ah.
I still got poison anyway!
Rude.
Oh, I don't need to save.
I don't think...
Wait, what?
I might be good to save just in case.
Okay.
The one of these?
This one?
Wow.
Oh!
Oh, Peach!
No magic for Peach.
Here?
That doesn't seem right.
Oh.
Oh, okay, that was some heavy hitting.
Hello?
Oh?
Casino!
Please enjoy yourself.
You're not allowed to get it?
Welcome to Great Guy's Casino.
Want to play the prize blocks?
No? Not yet.
As you wish.
Hello, Mario!
I'm here in this casino.
Feel free to enjoy yourself.
Welcome to the memory table.
Play a game with me.
As you wish, like this.
Hit it once to start the game.
Each consecutive hit will freeze on one of the pictures.
Match up three and you'll win the prize.
Want to try it out? Yeah.
Does it cost money?
Shit.
Are the games, sir?
No?
I wonder what became a booster search for a bride.
This is so slow.
Hey Mario, want to play a look the other way with me?
At the end, look the other...
Wait!
Oh, you didn't get caught. I lost this round.
Here, you can have this.
Oh, mushroom. Try it again.
No? Wait, is it just free?
You think you're so hot, but you're not.
Really?
Yeah, sure.
Okay.
I will show you the cards that are in your position carefully.
Shit!
I am not good at memorizing.
Oh shit! I was so close!
Eels.
That's correct.
Card is beaches.
Each card is Bowser's.
Like you won, Mario, please accept your prize.
Got a finless cola.
Yeah, I want to play again, sorry.
Okay.
Best beaches.
Bowser's here.
That one's Mario.
Yay!
Eno.
Mario.
Sorry, I love gambling, but not really gambling.
It's free gambling, therefore it's good.
Mario.
Peach.
Hello?
Yeah!
Okay, I'm good now.
What about this one?
Oh, right and left on L.
Yay!
My room.
What am I supposed to do?
Okay.
I just want to play it for free, man.
Man.
Fuck.
My life sucks.
I can't, I can't do this anymore.
Wah!
Do I get a special prize if I, like, win a lot?
I think he's stronger than these guys, maybe.
He's hoping for more money.
Aren't these guys Bowser's friends?
Oops.
Pro Goomba? Pro Goomba?
Yeah.
Bowser's scaring the Pro Goomba.
I forgot this is my meekness.
Okay.
At least I ran away.
He's just looking at him.
Bowser's scaring the Malacupas.
I'm so glad this is a thing.
He's just there, he's like...
It was fun.
Huh.
The Forky is enraptured, by what?
Shit.
Forky has come to his senses.
Forky, forky, forky.
Okay.
I need to, like, jump on it?
And...
Is this gonna be good enough?
Okay.
Oh, well, good enough. And a Froggy coin.
Get out of here, I need Bowser.
Okay.
There we go.
Where'd he go? He just died.
Did you see that one?
He's dumb too, he's doomed.
Imara, did you remember to use save point?
It's funny and dangerous ahead, so it's best to save now.
You need anything? Got some items to sell.
Wait, you're selling me stuff?
Wait, I already have all of these, right?
Oh, no, thanks. Thank you.
There are six doors, need an explanation? Yes.
Of the six doors.
Two open into action courses. Can you handle all that?
You can handle all the actions, right?
No!
Others will lead you to battle courses, you can fight, right?
The last two option, into puzzle courses.
You like to...
No sweat for great puzzle solvers like you, right?
Once you choose a course, there's no turning back.
The only way to know what's behind a door is to walk through it.
You must pass four of the six courses to move ahead.
Eh, I'm the quiz master, you can call me Dr. T.
You need to coin collecting, eh?
Instructions? Yes.
There are 21 coins in this box.
We'll take turns removing them.
The one who takes the last coin is a loser.
Grab four at once.
If you want to grab only one or two, press A.
Or you want to stop, okay?
I actually don't know how to play this.
Where are we?
Yeah, you got the last coin you lose.
I-I did?
Wait, I did?
That was 19, not 20.
Oh.
Alright, that was my bad.
Hey, hey, it's me, the quiz master, and it's quiz time!
Need an explanation? Yeah.
Be 12 count.
Count them, 12 questions.
You're right, the block you're standing on will move up,
but if you blow it, you go two down.
Five seconds if you can't answer, you move down one.
Reach the A step within the 12-plus,
and then you won, got it?
The first monster you see in the pipe, uh, vault.
Uh, Goomba?
Shit.
It's the full boss of the name, uh, Jonathan Jones.
Peter Fitch is a what?
A boss?
Mario Malon, Peach's triple move is called what?
Healing Rainbow?
What is the fourth option on the menu?
Specials?
Fuck.
How long has the couple inside the chapel been waiting for their wedding?
An hour?
Fuck.
What did the red essence do?
Relieved back pain?
Fuck.
Watch this, uh, female beetle cell for fraud coin?
No!
The man getting his picture taken up, Marymore hates what?
Getting his picture taken?
Up you...up the cliff ends.
Uh, Power Troopers.
How many likes does Wiggler have?
Eight?
Shit.
Where's their...
therapy fo-mobile?
Fuck.
I can't remember these.
I forgot.
Was that, was that three?
I like that one.
Fuck.
Ah!
Wait, I want to go back.
No!
Ah!
How come I can't reach it?
Oh, I spawned.
Fuck.
We have seven chances left.
Ah, my coins!
Fuck.
I don't like this.
I want to give up.
No!
Give me the quiz again!
I don't want to give up.
I'll do this again!
Fuck.
What is the cinder tore out in charge of the middle counter in I can't remember these hold on
I'm gonna try it again
Jinx
Level 15 uh crusher
A crooked pie
30 minutes
Ladida
Future
Fort
There's the ultimate enemy in this adventure smithy
Yeah, I'm done. I guess that was a warm up for you, huh?
Thanks
Let's see how well you can count give me 10 seconds 10 tell me the number of barrels in this room
Oh fuck
Oh, give me a second one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
Never mind
One two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
Fourteen right fifteen
Fifteen yeah next this is correct
Hey, where are we going?
See if you can really count you've got only 20 seconds ready
I got 44 what do you think
47 shit, I didn't I didn't click in time
Do I have to start all I have to start over
So
I
Don't want to be here anymore
Fifteen right
Is it the same one is it the same question or is it different amount
So
47 is not correct
Double touch
So
This one's 12 right
No, I
Thirteen
Sixteen
I trust you
I
Can't count one two three life
35 okay, I trust all you all
I
Just you all I can't count
What the hell is this
Boo boo
Bones and kip completely competed in a triathlon
Triathlon
Do you want us to help with this maybe the triathlon includes swimming cycling and a marathon
You
Have to you to guess which place each person came in so listen to what they have to say
I
Outdid bones both on my bike and in the final rankings
Down and forth during the bike race, but finally ended up in the same place as I did in the swimming event shit
It placed in the same the same in swimming and cycling event, but the other two beat me in the marathon
I didn't write this down
Senpai is this timed
Hold on I didn't take notes
So
Sorry I need to talk to you again
I outdid bones
Okay
Bones, you know is fourth in the bike
Mark and swimming
You
Came in third for swimming never did better at events after that
So kip
Wait, what do you mean you came in third for swimming you're a fish
You're a fish
What the heck
Okay, let's start with some oh some some mine stuff
Give me a second. Where did they place right?
Okay, and below for everything else
Okay goo got the same in swimming and cycling
Beep bo bo beet bones on bike and final
So bones definitely got fourth
Okay, so bones was fourth. Okay, let's do god damn. I don't have no notes for this
Okay, so in biking
Bones there are four of them
Okay, so one two three four, so bones got fourth
So that means bones is fourth
Kip is third because kip never got better in anything past that
Boo beep bones on bike and the final
And goo was the same in
Swimming and cycling
So I'm gonna guess two is boo
So
Can I talk to the goomba goomba says they got the same in swimming and cycling
I
Can do it again
See I place this
Same in swimming and cycling and two others beat me in the marathon
I out did bones on my bike and the final rankings
Merit remember the marathon is the last event, okay
Okay, so boo could possibly I mean goo could have been the first
I
And boo
Definitely beat kippin bones
So
So kip said came in third for swimming and never did better in the any events so
Third is swimming and there's only one
So said bones says fourth so that's last place
Ah
This is that does that mean kip could have gotten higher in cycling no maybe
What was the what was the uh, sorry, what was the order of things?
Swimming
No, it was swimming cycling marathon, so if you came third for swimming, that's the first event
So
Kip says he didn't do better in the events after swimming
Yeah, swimming's the first event, so he never did anything better than that
So if we're going I'm going by biking first because we know
that
um
Bones here look bones says
Was fourth place in the bike race so bones
Is definitely number four
Kip said never did better better than third place so kip is the next one
Now we don't know about boo and goo
So goo said I found the same
Swimming and cycling events, but the other two beat me in the marathon
And
Boo said I doubted bones, so it's it's a throw up between who did better
Uh goo or boo in the biking event. So now the swimming event
One two three four
Two three four we know kip
did
third
again
In the swimming
And then hold on marathon
One two three four
So two people
Beat
goo in marathon
So that means goo was in third for marathon
And that means
Kip
Was last in marathon
So boo did better than bones
Okay, I did the same place as I ended up in this swimming event
So
Bones would be one or two for the swimming event
So that means
I outdid that
I
That means boo
Boo probably won goo is in second place for biking. Sorry got it boo
Then goo then kip them bones for biking
And I'm in the same place as I did in this swimming event
Place the same in swimming and cycling so that means goo
If cycling that means swimming goo would have been in second place
So
Two others beat me in the marathon that means you were third place
Need to figure out our bones was
And kip says I'd never did better than third
I need swimming
Boo was last then
So
Or I'm trying to figure out the swimming so kip did third I think goo would have gone second then
Since I think
Boo beat bones on the bike
Swimming and cycling
I
But goo said I ended up in the third place. Sorry, I'm confusing myself
Okay, hold on I
Do is third
I place the same in swimming and cycling events
But the other two beat me in marathon
Sorry, I need bones I fell into fourth place during the bike
But finally ended up in the same place as I did the swimming
So
I'm confusing myself
Oh
So
Wait the final ranking and the wait wait wait hold on the final ranking
Is not the same as the marathon
So
No, it is the same as the marathon so the final ranking is the marathon
The winners of the marathon are the winners overall
Wait the marathon is final though, doesn't that mean it's the final
Semantics here is so hard
I don't know anything about splits
So
Hold on give me a second
I gotta do this again I'm getting confused I I'm overthinking
I
Don't know what the final versus the marathon is that's the issue right now
I thought there was only three
But if there's like a final ranking where where like you put odd things together that makes things different
I'm overthinking that's my weakness
You came third in swimming
So this means this is kip
And kip's always either third or fourth
Goom says
Two others beat me in the marathon so that means
Goo was third
And bone says fourth place in the bike race so we know
Bones if bones is fourth fourth is the last place
So that means kip ever did better than three so we know kip
Is third in that so for the bike
Bike race we know exactly where kip and bones are
So
If goo and then we know
Goo was third that means kip was last bottom tier in marathon
That's all we know so far. So these are the guaranteed ones
Now we don't know if
Goo or boo got in first or second
But we do know that goo placed the same in swimming and cycling
So they're the same in the cycling so it's either first or second first or second for goo
Bone says I fell in the fourth place during the bike race, but finally ended up in the same place as I did in the swimming event
So that means boo has to be above
Above
The bones
So
Wait I placed the same in swimming and cycling events, but the other two beat me in the marathon
Okay, who's almost the same
Swimming and cycling goo was either first or second
Goo
Wasn't third. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah goo was in third because others to beat him. So we know the guaranteed so far
bike is one two either goo or boo
Old bike kip
bones
Because bone said they were in fourth, but kip never did better than third. So kip goes on top
kip also
was
Is fourth in the marathon and third in the uh
Swimming because that's where they said it is so we know all the locations of kip. We don't need
kip's fucking opinion anymore
We don't need kip's fucking opinion anymore. It's the other three we're having problems with we place kip
Everywhere already
So all we know is that bones even though was in fourth
Had to be in either
Second
So if
Second or third
No second no second or first but if
Hold on
Swimming swimming and the marathon were the same. I mean bones was
Yeah, bones is is second for both of them
Swimming and cycling
Boo got first in marathon then
Swimming and cycling what two others beat me in the marathon
Goo is first
In bike
And swimming I think that's the only place I can think of
Boo came in first in the marathon
So
On the fourth but ended up in the same. Yeah, yeah, yeah
I think I got it
I
Got it
Since this is the only places that they can
They can place I think
Okay, I think I got it
I think I got it if I'm wrong that was me
Maybe
Wait
The order that they came in
Wait wait for what event or what event go talk to the one the first one in the final what event
The the whole event the marathon, okay, that means boo went first. Yes
Uh bones came in second
Goo came in third
And kip came in last
I'm not actually sure
Yeah, I did it I'm so smart but stupid at the same time
What's this rock candy?
I got everyone in there their places because I was like, okay, this is the only places they can go after a while
Oh
Thank you teabird for the five
Always one again
Some pie
He sat thank you for the two he sat oh did you come on we were in we were in for 30 minutes. Good job
I feel a little insulted. It's just the battle room
Oh, I didn't have to battle at all
So
Oh god damn it. I don't actually know what
It's strong against them
Oh
I
I'm gaming
Thank you for the five he sat so did you I apologize if it's taken as in so far be bgm girl me insane
The bgm was pretty brutal. Yeah, but did you guys also solve it?
I
Solved it so I know it took a while, but I was like shit. I have to confirm
I I already got out the pen and paper. Yeah
I
Not complaining that I took long if you didn't even do it
That's my only thing is that don't no complain if I took too long if you didn't even do it
I
Not trying to be mean but
It's like it's like those
It's one of my pet peeves where someone's like I could do this better than you and I'm like why aren't you then
But I don't think you meant it that way so I'll forgive you
Oh
There you go, they all died
How long are these battle things a lot of battles
It's pink mouse
Kind of cute
Oh
Goodbye you little shit
Oops I press the wrong button for that. Why did I press that button?
I forgot what these guys are they're the splatoon kids thing, right?
I
We
These guys are actually leaflings. Where's Yoshi? Okay
There we go
I
Do it again
Yeah die
Ah
Oh
That's easier than I thought yay
Yay
Wait how many are these
Wait, wait, how many are these there's too many
They like three stages each time or is it fourth stages
I
Like three be each time, huh
Yeah
Another one
Bowser
Whoa
I don't want to do all the stages at once. I hope there's like a save point soon
I'm getting tired
Okay, there's Yoshi
There's Yoshi
I'm too tired now
Oh, no not this bitch
I
How much was inside
Am not lying to you
When is this thing gonna fucking die?
I
Was taken forever, you know who everyone leveled up
You
Let me in
Star gun, what's that?
What
Oh, that's a really good weapon. Okay, let's go
I'm so tired another this thing maybe
You take me for a fool I'm not good at this
I
Do
Yeah, you went nothing to do it to it, huh
The fuck is this topic you ask the magic buttons
My instructions yes, please
Yes, step on one button and you reverse the surrounding buttons
So on becomes off and off becomes on get it
If you can set them all on the on can you do that? I don't know
Oh man, that was my bed
I can't do this anymore man
I fucked up already
Hold on let me just go into my corner
Am I doing I'm my brain fry is gone
I reset
I'm so stupid right now
There we go, we're good. Sorry, I'm good right now. There's this
Now the topic is ball solitaire. I hate solitaire
instructions, yeah
You kick a ball it'll leapfrog an adjacent ball which will then disappear
So keep making balls disappear until one remains you can't kick a ball into a space occupied by another ball
And the ball you kick must always leapfrog another ball got it
What
What was the instructions I'm sorry what?
Wait, how do I do that?
Do I jump over the balls myself wait
I'm sorry, I'm confused, but how do I leapfrog them?
How do I kick them
Oh
Oh, I see like this. Oh understood
Oh like I can just go like this
So
Oh
It's wrong
Wait, I have to do it all over again. Shit
I didn't realize
I
Wait, did I fuck up? Yeah, I got the last coin fuck
Oh
Wait, I miscounted fuck I miscounted
Sorry, I miscounted
I'm so tired
Maybe I should do this later
Oh
Wait
You got it. Oh, you just let me win, huh?
That's when I was very brain empty
Oh
Oh, no, I was so brain empty for this one
I'm still brain empty
I
Let's brain empty
Okay, this one
Oh
Can I kick diagonally
Just one direction
Well, I think I already fucked up
Oh
I
I'm gonna get kicked out again. I don't think I can recover
If I kick if I kick this one
Backwards
I
Do this one where I can go like this and if it's here then I can't then no one else is here to get it
Because then it goes over here this one disappears it's here
Then it's all alone, right
I
Leftmost one
This one
Okay
I'm so bad at this
I like to kick this thank you
This one
This one right
Oops
Kick this one
And if I bounce
This one that's okay, right
I send this one over and I'll land here
Then this one can bounce over it wait now wait what?
It's recoverable
I
Wait hold on
I can also send this one over here
But then this one won't have anything this one will have to kick over here think
Wait this one
Can this one kick first
This one will have to go here
But then after that it's lost
I need to get rid of this one too
Oh no
Okay
You figured it out hold on this one
Have to kick into here
I'll land here
This one
There's two directions this this one I can go over here and make it disappear. Yeah
This one right
I think this one
And then me a second
This one goes
Here
But then it gets stuck here so that one can't move this one
Wait, but then I need this one too
This one to go here
Yeah, this one has to go here right this one has to go here
Right
And then
Do I kick then this one goes over here hold on I'm giving
My best yes, I think this will work
We kick this one right
Wait
This one wait kick this one again to the right
This one
Wait what I'm sorry
My brain hurt I can't do this right now top one
Oh
Yay, oh simple as ABC's a no, they're not let me out of here
Rock candy or rock candy in storage
I'm fucking screwed. Where is the save room?
I don't want an obstacle course
There's
A room doggle
Remember this one is oh no this one is an obstacle course
There is another battle path, which one is it?
Oh
I
We're good
Big Koopa
I
I'm so sleepy
Holy fuck I'm tired
I'm so tired brain broken this part killed me
I want to cry
I
Want well, we'll beat this room and then I don't know man
Is right there
I
Don't want to do with this anymore just go
I spot the Yoshi like I spot my supplies
I think it's because I woke up early today again
Mr. Kipler, mr. Go on
I
Have a really bad feeling that if this boss that this boss is
The upcoming boss Smithy
Is gonna be really hard because I remember playing thousand year door and
The witch lady was like extremely hard
Which lady was extremely hard and
Yeah, and then I played
um
Super Mario brother superstar and that boss was really hard
So I have got a bad feeling this is gonna be really hard
A glum weeper
I
Oh fuck, I got it wrong this time.
Wow, that's amazing.
I got it wrong for once, I must be so tired.
I must be that tired, huh?
Oh fuck, I got it wrong this time, I must be so tired.
Oh my gosh, I've gone silent mode.
I've gone silent mode because all I want to do is make this be over.
We're almost there!
Gaming takes all the focus, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
We're... alright.
Oh my god, I feel like I'm being cheated right now.
I'm tired.
It's over, my Yoshi pal.
My Yoshi powers, it's over.
There's no exclamation marks anymore.
We're almost there, my Yoshi pal.
Okay, I still got it.
I still got it.
A drill claw, what the hell is a drill claw?
Oh, okay.
Oh, some Baoziboo.
Finally, a save.
Actually, that's it.
We're saving here, period.
I'm gonna do it again.
Double tap and case high.
Case high, start crying.
It's freedom.
We can get some sleep now.
Like this.
A big,
a big, a big schedule time.
Guess what, sis?
Tomorrow,
it's more
wild arms.
Also get a chest working, woohoo.
It's more wild arms.
After that,
nothing.
Behold, I give you on Wednesday, nothing.
More shoot,
more wild arms,
more plot.
Hopefully, I remember the buttons.
After that, on Thursday,
we're gonna try Killer Seven again.
We're gonna try.
But there is a
chance
I might cancel it
if I just don't think I have the skills to do it.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know if I can actually be good at Killer Seven.
It might change to like
something really easy, like
it might change,
the game might change into like a
like a visual novel or something.
Something really easy.
Something that's like
brain turn off,
only just read.
But it really depends.
I'm hoping that
when I practice off-stream a little bit,
that I'll be good.
And if I'm not, and I start crying,
we're probably not gonna play Killer Seven.
Friday is an ASMR stream.
Mayhaps,
Senpais have noticed that the other Vealore girls
have also
scheduled ASMR.
It's a
ASMR train.
All day ASMR
for your ears and tingles.
It's an ASMR train.
All day, six hours
of tingles.
It ends with me.
It ends
and starts with Icy.
We're basically following our own schedule,
but this time
we're...
But this time,
we're only doing, I think,
two hours each,
and then we end
and then immediately raid
into each other,
and it will end with me.
Because I usually,
and I usually stream the latest, right?
So that day, I hope everyone can enjoy it,
because
I didn't know if I was being announced or not
on the official one,
but it was planned to be an ASMR train.
So, six hours of Vealore girls
trying to tingle the heck out of you.
And then on Saturday,
if you are a member
of the snippet tier or hire,
which there is no hire, there's only just that.
There is no hire,
he's a joke.
Although you...although YouTube will tell me
this one or hire.
Just like, anyone on this tier or hire,
and then I'm just like,
wait, but...
YouTube, it can't get any higher than that.
You all have an exclusive
cat girl ASMR.
With me!
Mercy!
Oh!
With me, Mercy, not Merciel.
Not Merciel.
Ohio, wow, everyone's feeding me again.
Mercy, when did you get here?
Oh yeah, it's been a while, huh?
I decided to take over after Merciel.
I figured Mercy,
Merciel's getting tired,
but so am I, it's been a long day.
Yeah, Merciel right into Mercy.
You and Merciel share a similar face?
No.
Merciel has a mustache and a big button nose.
I don't have a mustache.
I don't have a mustache, we're completely different.
No.
We're completely different.
Is this Lord Secret's brother name?
No, Merciel has a brother name...
Lushibi.
I thought the Merciel gained three sisters.
Do you think sisters will have such an amazing girl,
glorious stash with a huge button nose?
I don't think so.
I ask you this, have you ever seen,
seen Merciel from the chest, from the neck down?
I don't think so.
Or at least I don't recall.
Anyway, yeah, you have, you have a membership with me.
And it will be my first time doing a cat girl ASMR.
Please do not judge me on how bad I purr.
Or at least be nice to me, but I will do my best to be super nice to my wonderful owners.
I'm probably not going to purr to sing.
Did you practice purring at all?
I don't want to talk about it.
I don't want to talk about my purring.
I'm pretty sure it's terrible.
It'll be the one in the cage this time.
You leave your cat in a cage all day?
No.
Cats must, must cause havoc when you get home.
The cat is free.
Can we get a purring sample please, Kohai?
No.
It will just sound like I'm gurgling like frogs or something.
Also, that should be only exclusive to the, to the, to the, to the, to the, what do you call it?
Member stream anyways.
It should be only exclusive to the members stream anyways.
It's only exclusive to members and you will have to see it all that day.
And then after that, Sunday is a day off.
And then I'd like to, and then I already have the following week scheduled.
And then after that, I'll post up the schedule for the following week.
And then we have another full week together.
But the following week, the week after next week,
starting on the 8th to the 14th will be my vacation time.
I'm going out with the girls.
I don't know what we're doing.
Going out of town.
I think we might be going camping, but it doesn't look like we're, we have like a plan set yet.
I'm not doing the itinerary this time the girls are.
So, um, I'll see, I'll see.
Oh, I'll probably won't know until like I get there or like maybe it's going to be like one of those things where we just kind of,
we kind of just like do whatever, you know?
So that will be my vacation.
I haven't taken like a real vacation in a while.
My last vacation was, well, going to Vietnam and then visiting family.
And that didn't really feel like a vacation at all.
You know?
I didn't feel like a vacation at all.
Just feel, felt like, you know, like a duty.
It felt like a duty because, you know, it was family.
Yeah.
It's doing stuff with family.
And then like, uh, it was like visiting family and then also going to,
to like, I think we were, uh, what's the word?
Well, what was the word?
Uh, like, I had a lot of things like, um, had to, had to go to like visit family graves and stuff and pray,
uh, pray since, uh, there's some, and then also like, uh, kind of being like meeting,
meeting, um, meeting up with family members I haven't seen in a long time,
which was a lot of it was countryside stuff.
It was not, it wasn't a relaxing experience.
No.
Every day I had to go to a new, new, new place and then meet, meet new family members
or extended family members.
And yeah, it was, it was a lot.
It was a lot.
So it didn't really feel like a vacation vacation.
I think I went to the beach like twice and that was it.
Even though I took the fight quite some time off, it didn't feel like a real vacation.
So this one hopefully feels like a real vacation.
Hopefully.
Okay.
Is the water warm at the beaches there?
Uh.
No, it's, it's, it's okay.
It's cool, but it's not like cold.
You know what I mean?
The only thing I didn't like was that it was kind of dirty.
Like the beach was really dirty and full of litter and it made me really sad.
Made me really sad and I got really, really, really pissed because like plastic and stuff
were cutting my ankles.
So I was very upset with the state of the beach.
I got stung by a jellyfish in Vietnam.
Not a great time.
I'm sorry about that.
But yeah, I didn't really enjoy the beach because like it was, there was so much litter
and I felt so sad.
I tried to clean it up, but like there was just so much, you know?
So I wasn't, it wasn't a good thing.
I can't, I couldn't do it by myself or anything either.
And I feel like it had to be, had to be like, uh,
it has to be like a, a like, like a work thing.
Like someone has to get paid to like do it.
I didn't have any like garbage bags with me either.
So all I could do was just put it in like a, like in a corner, you know?
That's it.
So that's generally, um, so that's why I was like, uh, yeah, it requires a really big effort.
There was so much, there was so much garbage.
I just couldn't do it.
It was not an effort that I could do alone.
Otherwise it would take off on my vacation time as well.
So yeah, it was just like, oh, you know, your, your picture perfect,
like beach experience was not exactly picture perfect.
So yeah, hopefully, so I'm going to have a mini vacation probably.
I'll probably be just like hanging out with girls, with girls.
So during that time, I hope some pies be good and hold each other accountable.
Make sure no one escapes or has wandering eyes.
So I trust my senpais.
I'm not sure if we're going camping.
If we are going camping, there's probably not going to be any signal like at all.
So I might not be able to update, uh, anyone about anything.
So that is, is a risk.
Yeah.
So yeah, that's about it.
That's all I have for today.
Um, I'm going to go eat.
I don't know.
I'm so tired today and usually I can go for much longer,
but I'm just exhausted right now.
I'm so exhausted.
What do you think you'll find out about the itinerary?
Honestly, probably the day of.
Probably the day of because the girls are kind of like that.
They do everything super last minute.
It's a surprise.
I don't know what it's going to be.
So I'm going to be flexible and as long as we have a place to stay or we have plans
and I know a little bit ahead of time, what we're doing that I can prepare.
Luckily, if it's camping, I have all the camping gear that I can bring right away.
So that's not an issue.
That's not an issue.
I'm pretty prepared for that.
But if it is like, oh, it's just like, you know, staying at a hotel going out to cafes
and like going to like museums, then that's nice too, you know?
Those are nice too.
Or if there's like an event happening that they're going to bring me to, I don't really know.
So thank you, senpai, for joining me today.
Even though my brain is fried and my gaming skills, mainly the platforming skills, it's also fried.
So I love you all.
Nobody's on, right?
Usually when I'm streaming, nobody's streaming.
I don't think I see anyone.
So I'm just going to end it here.
Thank you for joining me today.
And I'll see you again tomorrow.
Today.
Tomorrow, which is considered today.
Yeah.
Okay, scream for mercy.
Bye-bye.
Thank you.